Elon Musk has just said that George
Soros hates Humanity Soros I don't know
I mean he had a very difficult
upbringing um and uh I in my opinion he
fundamentally hates Humanity that's my
opinion really yeah I mean well he's
doing things that erod the fabric of
civilization you know uh getting Das
elected who refuse to prosecute crime
that's part of the problem in San
Francisco and la and much of other
cities so why would you do that as is
often the case Elon Musk spot on here
this is the irony with humanists and
humanitarians is the humanists and the
humanitarians they suggest that they are
exalting mankind that they are
perfecting humanity and all they want is
for Humanity to live up to its full
potential
and the way they're going to do that is
by getting rid of all those stupid
things we believed in the past we're
going to get rid of religion that only
holds us back and makes us fight each
other and it's not very inclusive and
it's not diverse and Equitable or
whatever the modern jargon is we're
going to get rid of all the Traditions
we're going to get rid of all the normal
bonds and relationships we're going to
up in the whole world we're going be
revolutionary But the irony is that the
humanists and the humanitarians end up
degrading human
beings when you when you have God in
your perspective and all the things that
go along with God religion civilization
inspiration when you have that mankind
becomes most perfectly himself because
man is made in the image and likeness of
God so when your Society is oriented
toward God you become more perfectly who
you really
are when you take God out of the
equation and you you say we're going to
be humanists we're going to be we're
going to only focus on Humanity we're
not going to focus on all those other
moral or religious considerations and
rights and obligations we're just going
to focus on human beings humans are the
greatest thing of all we're going to
turn humans into Gods we're going to
write a book like yal Harari wrote
called homod
Deus ironically what you do is you
degrade humans because you're forgetting
what humans are supposed to be you're
forgetting who in whose image the humans
are made and so you make humans like
animals you make humans like computers
we start talking about humans like
machines or we start talking about
humans as no different from irrational
beasts we're just flesh we're just
hormones and synapses and pistons firing
we believe we pretend that we have
rational thought but we don't really we
know that that's just an illusion you're
just a cog you're just a machine you're
like a computer we're going to hack you
you're going to have a hackable we're
going to biohack your body and we're
going to transform you we're going to
upgrade the software whatever stupid
language they use so ultimately they
degrade you Humanity this has always
been the case right now go to peer
talk.com peer talk announced that they
would alleviate $10 million in veteran
debt by veteran day thanks to your
support these last few weeks Pure Talk
is 74% to that goal with two weeks to go
now just think about this we have a 100%
volunteer military men and women who
raise their hands to sacrifice for this
country and when they're done serving
they come back to a tight job market and
an outrageous cost of living expenses
that is why I am so happy a private
company like pure talk has jumped in to
help when you switch to P talks
Lightning Fast 5G Network they will
donate a portion of every new order to
this noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell phone service pure talks plans
start at just 20 bucks a month offering
unlimited talk text more data and a
mobile hotspot just go to Pur
talk.com kwes make the switch let's
rally together show our unwavering
support of our veterans P talk.com
switch to P talk today it's the right
move and it's theer American way right
now go to Ru greens.com my stepbrother
has been giving his dog Ru greens and
his dog is loving it well the dog isn't
loving it because dogs don't have
rational souls and they're incapable of
love but I am sure that the dog finds
the rough greens appetizing and the ru
greens are definitely very good for the
dog's health naturopathic doctor Dennis
black the founder of rough greens is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America dog food may as well be
considered dead food because it contains
very little nutritional value nutrition
isn't Brown it's green let rough greens
bring your dog's food back to life rough
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't even have to go out and buy new
dog food you can just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every single day
dog owners everywhere are raving about
it and Dr Dennis black right now is so
confident that rough greens will improve
your dog's health he's offering our
listeners a free jump start trial bag so
that your dog can try it get a free jump
start trial bag delivered straight to
your door in just a few business days go
to Ruff greens.com Michel m h AE l or
call 844 ru1 123 that is R ufff
greens.com Michael or you can call 8844
Ru 123 even George Soros he's a tragic
figure to me because the thing I think
of first when I think of George Soros is
Esperanto to me Esperanto explains
George Soros this this is a man who grew
up his father was one of the leaders of
creating espiranto and promoting it this
this failed Universal second language
it's a language that was just concocted
it's a contrivance and it was supposed
to be the the second language for all
the people who speak all these different
languages that's how they would all
converse with one another and we'd all
come together kumaya and the irony is
there already was a universal second
language for thousands of years in the
west and that language is Latin and it
was precisely at the time that all these
new modern hip liberal people said we
got to get Latin out of out of life
we've got to latin's a dead language we
got to forget that all of a sudden it
was exactly at that time that they said
hey wait we need a universal second
language so they can dve this thing
espiranto which is just inhuman in fact
if you try to teach little kids to speak
espiranto they they will naturally make
it more complicated because life isn't
so simple and and and we human beings
are just not that good at playing God
we're we're not we actually can't create
the universe better than it was already
created and George Soros was a childhood
speaker of Esperanto and he is a big
promoter of it just as he's a big
promoter of all of these human
contrivances to remake the world after
our own image not going to work very
well very very degrading speaking of
humanitarians democrat representative
Jason Crowe is voting
against Republican speaker Mike
Johnson's Israel support bill because it
quote politicizes
Israel I'm not going to support this
bill it's a horrible horrible bill it's
horrible for Israel because it actually
doesn't have any humanitarian Aid
funding uh so like I've long said
there's no uh sole military solution to
this we have to couple humanitarian Aid
and protection of civilians with the
military response and if we don't do
that neither one of those will be a
success so there has to be humanitarian
funding but they have politicized this
effort to support Israel in a way that
is unacceptable it sets a precedent that
these National Security supplementals
will be subject to politics in a way
that we never have subjected in the
politics before and I'm just not going
to stand for it I'm going to stand up
and say there's a bipartisan way of
doing this in a way that we have always
done in the past and we're not going to
allow this to be
politicized the Republicans have
apparently politicized support for
Israel what does that mean what what on
Earth does that mean
how do you politicize a congressionally
ratified military aid package to a
foreign government was that that wasn't
political before what was that that was
just kind of cultural man you know it
was just artistic and spiritual it was
personal it wasn't political when our
duly elected representatives vote to
spend taxpayer money on a military aid
package to support a foreign nation in a
war that's not political give me a break
what that that is one of the phrases
that drives me craziest in modern
politics is when people accuse their
opponents of politicizing
something what does that mean political
means public that's all it
means if if an issue is of public
interest it is by definition a political
matter this one is just extremely
ridiculous because we're talking about
International diplomacy and foreign aid
well that was previously was not a
political matter I guess what he means
is he they're making it party political
they're making it partisan but Mike
Johnson's not making it party political
he's saying hey we're going to vote to
give the Israeli government money you
guys want in and and a lot of Democrats
are saying no right now because it's a
wedge issue for the Democrats because
the Democrat donors support the state of
Israel and the Democrat base hates the
state of Israel so either way that the
Democrat representatives are damned if
they do and damned if they don't people
just
decry
politicization when they want to de
legitimize one's political opponents
when they say that's out your opinion is
outside the scope of politics and of
course they do that often because they
can't win a political debate including
at our inter our nation's deliberative
body man what a great clip that was huh
now hey hey hey hey man you got to ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael NS
YouTube channel we'll see you next time